we'll look at this summer's travel
trends and reveal a new global report by
american express it shows 76 percent of
families plan to travel more this year
70 percent plan to take their first
international trip with kids since the
pandemic that's a big jump from the last
two years when just 10 traveled
internationally and then 19
didn't go anywhere at all cbs news
senior travel advisor peter greenberg is
here joining us right now peter good
morning um let's jump right into it so
gas prices are soaring they are um so
how does this impact how people are
going to travel right now well not as
much as you think right now but domestic
bookings are surging hotel rates are
going up nearing 2019 levels and as a
result good luck trying to get into a
national park this summer even a state
park so if you don't make your domestic
travel booking soon
a you may not get in and b if you do
you're gonna pay a whole lot more oh boy
uh you mentioned train travel as an
alternative to driving i'm not aware of
a trained destination that i could get
to that's what i think yeah i know we
always take we can you can go to
washington boston philadelphia on the
train i never think of that as a
vacation amtrak's had their best
ridership in years and they got the
long-haul trains coming back the zephyr
the empire building the cardinal the
southern crescent one of the great
trains ever started where are they going
where is it going it starts here in new
york stops in washington goes all the
way south to new orleans it's great you
fly somewhere to pick up the train
do you fly to penn station no
i mean you know you're talking about the
west yeah anyway all right you also have
some budget deals for families looking
to take multi-generational trips before
you get to those i do want to put up a
picture which shows a what are you guys
sure fire way to save money on a family
vacation
[Laughter]
60 off here nate burleson because three
children that he has not on the trip yes
no kids allowed we left the baggage
behind
oh i didn't mean to call my kid's
baggage but you know what i mean you
gotta do that with you my wife
but if you do want to take the kids or
even the grandkids how do you do it and
save money well that's what's happening
we saw this before after 9 11. we saw it
again after the 2008 economic debacle
we're seeing it now when we have a
crisis whether it's in ukraine or at the
pump
families tend to come together and then
travel together as multi-generational
entities and that's happening all across
the board highly recommended hotel train
cruise or maybe in your case yeah now
what about flying peter is is now a good
time to go to europe are more people
going to europe now or more people
coming to the united states and what's
the difference
more people are not going to europe now
because of what's going on in eastern
europe but if you're a smart traveler
and you get the map out you'll realize
that airfares to europe have plummeted
there are great deals at home now would
be a good time to do it smartly but do
one more thing book it on a u.s carrier
because they got rid of those draconian
ticket change fees which means if you
have to cancel your trip you're not
going to lose your money what about
domestic travel in this country well
that's where we have a problem right now
airfares are rising at about seven
percent every month now they're rising
seven percent every week wow i'll give
you an example i was going from la to
san francisco a couple of weeks ago 93
round trip you know what that fare is
today 353
wow that'll give you an idea what's
going all across the board so if you're
a family of four
you can't afford those tickets that's
where you put everybody in the car strap
granny on the roof and off you go
although speaking of the car take that
back peter
granny don't want to be on the road
take that back peter okay
take that back uh speaking of cars this
is kind of bad news for detroit uh
according to the mx global survey the
travel report uh most people 65
said they would rather have a dream
vacation than a new car we've been going
way away from material goods
people are now valuing travel as an
experience that they want to keep and
that's what they're doing that's that's
what they're doing it's not about rate
it's about value and they can get the
car anywhere else but they can't have
the experience we have in a situation
like this what i call a last supper
mentality people are going now because
they're saying if i don't go now i'll
never go and what's your best advice
about traveling with covet because covet
guys is still here yeah i mean we're
relaxing all relaxing many of the
restrictions in terms of masks still
have to wear them on the plane but what
what's your best advice well the metric
right now don't test what well no a lot
of countries are getting rid of those
tests
not just the test to go but the test to
get there meaning once you're there we
still have the 24-hour rule to come home
but the bottom line is the metric is
based less on the vaccination levels
overseas or the hospitalizations than it
is on your vaccination level so you feel
safe to travel during these times yes
and we're coming up on a 270-day cut-off
and that is
well if you didn't get your vaccination
outside of 270 days you won't be let
into some of these countries so that's
why we're getting into that second
booster shot now the the cruise industry
got crushed early on kovid uh how's it
doing now and how can i convince my wife
to go on one and please speak directly
into that camera
i will she's afraid
bottom line with cruises is they're
doing better than ever the bookings are
strong and it gives you an idea of
pent-up demand last week a luxury cruise
line is called oceania put up for sale
their 2024 world cruise one of the most
expensive ticket items you can imagine
180 days the minimum cabin price 47 000
a person
it goes up to 190 000 get ready it's
sold out in 30 minutes
peter you get to travel all over the
world what's your dream vacation for you
what's your idea of a dream vacation
staying home no peter a little
staycation
okay if you had to pick something if you
had to i'm serious my metric is where i
sleep the best i'm serious i hear young
man yep when you sleep the best is where
you think the best is where you create
the best where you love the best it's
where you aspire to go back and
everybody's got one okay yeah mine is
drinking
yeah the travel expert who doesn't like
to travel oh i just like to travel
that's the problem i thought all i do is
travel okay all right peter greenberg
thank you it's always good to have you
here see your grandma
granny
on the roof
no thanks no thanks